Oh, hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Heute schon wieder Salon, es ist März und du bist frisiert.
Ich bin frisiert, es hat alles problemlos funktioniert. Ich hatte aber auch den ersten Termin. Es war ganz hervorragend und ich kann sagen, der Friseur ist auch so glücklich wieder arbeiten zu können. Das ist ja etwas, was auch sehr vergessen wird in dieser Debatte, wie wichtig das eigentlich für Menschen ist, dass sie dem Beruf nachgehen, den sie lieben.
Das stimmt, das stimmt, das stimmt. Wir kommen nachher darauf zurück. Es ist ja erstaunlich, es sind gerade die Berufe ausgeschnipst worden, die am Klienten, am Patienten, am Schüler, am was weiß ich. Und es sind genau die Berufe, die man mit Passion machen muss. Alle anderen Berufe, am Förderband, mit der Spitzhacke in der Hand, die durfte man weitermachen. Also die Jobs, wo man so ein bisschen denkt, na gut, ich kann auch jemand anderes, man spricht in der Soziologie von der Profession, dann wenn man tatsächlich am Menschen arbeitet. Es ist sozusagen von mir, auch wenn ich das anders tuniert habe, keine Klassifizierung dieser beiden Arten von Jobs. Aber es gibt einen großen, großen Unterschied. Und wir haben genau die Profession ausgenommen. Also genau die Arbeiten am anderen Menschen. Jetzt kommt es langsam zurück. Na gut, so. Letztes Mal haben wir hier eine Stunde über AstraZeneca gesprochen. Wir waren eigentlich nicht falsch zu verstehen. Einige haben natürlich doch auf Twitter mal versucht zu sticheln. Was habt ihr denn gegen AstraZeneca? Deswegen will ich es noch mal kurz aufgreifen. Gar nichts. AstraZeneca hat gegen Covid einen ganz tollen Impfstoff vorgelegt. Der hilft individuell spektakulär gut. Ist ein bisschen wie bei Johnson & Johnson. Die haben gestern schon mal so eine etwas längerfristige Studienauswertung gemacht. Man kriegt die eine Dosis nur bei Johnson & Johnson. Schon in Amerika zugelassen. Und dann wächst die Immunität so ein bisschen an. Bis sie dann ungefähr nach 2 Monaten wirklich bei 100% ankommt. Also wer 2 Monate nach dem Johnson & Johnson ein Virus-Input kriegt, kann es einfach abfangen. Da ist Immunität hergestellt. Das wird bei den anderen Impfstoffen auch so sein. Man boostet trotzdem noch mal nach. Übrigens auch sehr lustige Anleihen. Da habe ich einen amerikanischen Podcast gehört, dass bei Johnson & Johnson zu früh die Entscheidung getroffen wurde, nur einmal zu impfen. Das heißt, alle anderen Impfstoffhersteller können 2 Dosen pro Patienten verimpfen und damit auch abrechnen. Johnson & Johnson nur einen. Sie haben gedacht, das ist ja toll, dass wir hier sagen können, bei uns reicht eine. Dann kamen die BWLer um die Ecke und haben gesagt, liebe Virus-Ingenieure, was habt ihr euch hier überlegt? Wir müssen natürlich 2 verkaufen. Also in der Ansicht boosten wir alle gerne noch mal nach. In Deutschland verabschieden wir uns jetzt so langsam von dieser... Es muss pünktlich die zweite Impfung sein. Nein, man kann den Schrank jetzt leer impfen und dann irgendwann mal die zweite Impfung geben. Trotzdem gibt es bei AstraZeneca ein Problem. Wir haben es ja beschrieben, es ist ein Impfstoff zweiter Klasse. Und ich war wirklich überrascht, zum einen bei Kikolé nochmal zu hören, zweite Klasse heißt auch, wir haben ja ein großes Problem mit Mutation. Gerade wenn wir die Impfstrategie umstellen, auf erste Impfung erstmal machen, die zweite dann später, dann steigt der Mutationsdruck, weil das Virus dann erfolgreich wird, wenn es sich eben gegen die Impfung wehrt. Also gibt es einen Selektionsdruck hinzu, übersteht die Impfung. Und dann setzen sich diese wieder durch. Kalifornien wird jetzt kennengelernt, Südafrika und so weiter. Und jetzt heißt es, aber man kann ja AstraZeneca einfach updaten. Ja, das stimmt. Nur Menschen, die schon mal AstraZeneca geimpft bekommen haben, werden den Impfstoff komplett ab. Da kommt es gar nicht zu Kofferraum auf. Wie auch immer dieser Vektor-Virus da heißt, den man da als Vehikel nimmt. Da kann sein Kofferraum das gar nicht aufmachen, weil der Körper hat ja eine Immunität schon gegen dieses Virus durch die erste Impfung bekommen. Das heißt, AstraZeneca kann nicht einfach den Impfstoff updaten, sondern die müssen eine ganz neue Impfung entwickeln. Die brauchen dann ein neues Trägervirus. Für diejenigen, die beim ersten Trägervirus schon geimpft wurden, Kikule hat es ganz ausführlich. Ich spiele jetzt keinen Eclipse, aber da habe ich das mal getwittert. Da kann man es kurz nachhören, es geht nur eine Minute. Und das ist bei BioNTech und Moderna und CureVac natürlich anders. Weil der Körper kriegt eine Fetthülle, die sich einfach abbaut. Das ist ihre Funktion. Sie soll nur das Virus transportieren. Das Virus als RNA dringt in die Zelle, aber nicht in den Zellkern ein und macht ihren Dienst. Und diese Fetthülle, das Vehikel, muss überhaupt nicht geupdatet werden. Man kann einfach die zweite geupdatete Impfung bekommen. Kein neues Zuverlassungsverfahren von BioNTech. Kein Monate warten, sondern einfach einen Tag lang designen. Drei Tage lang einpacken in die Fetthülle. Vier Tage lang Test verimpfen. Und dann hat man nach drei, vier Wochen, und das hat ja Ugo Schahin auch schon gesagt, hat man nach vier Wochen eine neue Impfung. Eine abgedatete Impfung, die genauso funktioniert wie die erste, nur auf einen neuen RNA-Strang ausgerichtet ist. Und die nicht neu getestet und nicht neu zugelassen werden muss. Und dann habe ich heute Morgen, sorry, dass ich hier so monologe, aber ich habe heute Morgen was tolles gemacht.
Ja, mach mal, mach mal.
Ja, es gibt diesen Podcast Pivot. Aus dem habe ich für die Februar-Folge schon die Dispersion rausgezogen. Also ihr wisst, wovon ich rede. Scott Galloway und Carol Swisher reden da miteinander. Und die hatten jemanden aus der Taskforce von beiden dabei. Und dann haben sie mich mal gefragt, ja wie ist denn das jetzt, wie bekämpfen wir denn jetzt Corona? Und dann so, ja wir hoffen einfach mal, dass es so im Konzert von allem irgendwie hinhaut. Also es gibt diejenigen, die die Impfung entwickeln. Dann gibt es diejenigen, die die Impfen transportieren. Dann gibt es diejenigen, die die Impfen spritzen. Dann gibt es diejenigen, die als Politiker Zuversicht ausstrahlen. Dann gibt es diejenigen, die die Unterstützung zahlen, sodass die Leute bereit sind, nach einem Monat auf ihr Business zu verzichten, in der Erwartung, dass es dann ordentlich hinhaut. Und wenn das alles irgendwie gut klappt, dann hat man vielleicht irgendwann mal eine Lösung für Corona. Und das ist eine ganz andere Angehensweise, als wir in Deutschland immer denken, wir müssen noch schneller impfen und dann ist alles vorbei. Weil dann sind wir alle geimpft, dann sind wir alle immun. Stimmt ja nicht. Wir haben ja den Druck des südkoreanischen Virus, also der südkoreanischen Mutante, wie sie hier immer heißt. Und die wird sich natürlich dann durchsetzen. Sobald wir hier lockern, ist Ausdruck... Meint sie südafrikanisch? Ja, bricht die südafrikanische. Noch ist sie am einprozentigen. Drosten sagt, wir können sie noch mit der Hand abzählen. Aber da läuft ja eine Pandemie unter der Pandemie. Und wenn wir jetzt alle geimpft sind, nicht gegen die südafrikanische, was machen wir dann eigentlich? Zum einen, wir müssen viel mehr den Gesamtprozess betrachten, wie wir uns so langsam reingewöhnen, mit dem Virus zu leben. Das ist ja immer noch verpönt. Da hat ja selbst Herr Wieler Hans Naivität vorgeworfen in der Bundespressekonferenz am Freitag und meinte, wir können jetzt hier nicht auf Semantik achten, weil Hans so meinte, also Hans Jesen, ja, das ist jetzt nicht komische Sprache, wenn man jetzt sagt, wir müssen mit dem Virus leben lernen. Und dann meinte Herr Wieler vom RKI, ja, es ist halt ein Virus, mit dem wir jetzt leben lernen müssen. Also das geht nicht wieder weg. Wir können zwar einzelne Mutationen jetzt irgendwie weg verimpfen, aber dann müssen wir uns halt auf die nächste einstellen, bis es dann irgendwann mal in Jahrzehnten so runtergedimmt ist, dass es sozusagen das fünfte Erkältungsvirus ist, dass es ein Coronavirus ist und das wir einfach so mitmachen, weil wir genug Hintergrundimmunität haben und er nicht mal über eins steigen kann und so weiter und so fort. Da ist noch ungeklärt, wie machen wir das mit den Kindern? In Amerika sind 24% Kinder, die nicht in einem Alter sind, wo sie geimpft werden können. Herdenimmunität gibt es bei 85%, sagt Fauci. Da ist 1 plus 1 nicht 2. Das wird nicht aufgehen, jetzt einfach mit einer Impfung die Pandemie zu beenden oder die Epidemie, national bezogen. Und so müssen wir in Deutschland auch denken. Also wenn wir jetzt sagen, es war jetzt Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz, dann hören wir bei Lanz, wie es da so zuging. Weil Rolfin Alexander, der auch die ganzen SMSen bekommt, so wie die Bildkollegen da mal erzählt, wie es da so zugeht und wie sich alle nur noch beschimpfen. Das ist überhaupt nur der erste Schritt, diese Impfung. Also wir brauchen jetzt einen ganz großen, und zwar im Bill Gates-Maßstab gedachten, Forcierung von RNA-Impfstoffen, die wir monatlich updaten und uns auch gefahrlos verimpfen können. Und dieses Problem kriegen wir mit AstraZeneca und mit diesen alten Vektor-Impfungen niemals gelöst.
Dann sprechen wir von einem Dreivierteljahr, bis das geupdatet wäre. Du hast es ja dann gerade gesagt, es würde noch nicht mal helfen für diejenigen, die es schon bekommen haben. Also ist das ja dann überhaupt keine Zukunftstechnologie. Und ich wundere mich doch sehr, dass man über diese akute Notlage nicht hinausdenkt. Wir haben ja selbst gesagt, ja, jetzt in einer Notlage, wenn das andere nicht greifbar ist, man aber doch ein gewisses Risiko hat oder dem ausgesetzt ist, zum Beispiel Lehrer oder so ist, dass man dann sicherlich mit Astra besser bedient ist als mit nichts. Aber wenn wir dann mal denken, wie sieht es im Herbst aus, wie sieht es 2022 aus, dann kann doch niemand mehr festhalten an einer Technologie, die von einer Neuen abgelöst wurde, was man ja sonst auch nicht macht. Jetzt würde ja auch niemand mehr sagen, wir gehen mal wieder zur VHS-Kassette zurück.
Ja, wir müssen jetzt größer denken. Wir fangen mit der Impfung, die wir jetzt aktuell haben, fangen wir das ursprüngliche Coronavirus ab. Und wir wissen, es läuft schon die britische Variante, die südafrikanische, es kommt eine kalifornische. Die sind alle nicht aus der Welt. Wenn sie auftreten, treten sie auf. Und wir haben so viel Corona-Infektionen im Vergleich zu Masern oder sonstigen, dass die Mutationen sehr viel wahrscheinlicher werden. Und die setzen sich dann auch durch. Es ist wirklich wie bei der Grippe. Wir wissen nicht, im Januar, gegen was wir uns im November schützen müssen. So, mit diesen RNA-Impfstoffen, vielleicht hast du die Meldung auch gesehen, es gibt jetzt schon erste erfolgreiche Versuche gegen Malaria. Was für eine große Leerstelle war das auf der Welt, gegen Malaria zu impfen? Keine Infektionskrankheit im Sinne von Mensch zu Mensch, sondern kommt aus dieser Mücke, da ist man einfach nicht sicher in manchen Gebieten auf der Welt. Dagegen kann man jetzt impfen. Wir sehen dieses Potenzial von RNA und AstraZeneca. Sofort impfen lassen, hier in Frankfurt quillen die Schränke über. Man hat vergessen, die Leute einzuladen. Sie können sich allerdings aus eigener Kraft da reinklicken. Dann kriegen sie auch ihren Termin, teilweise noch am selben Tag. Ganz erstaunlich, wie viele Lagerbestände da sind. Nur damit kriegen wir nur das Wuhan-Virus in den Griff. Und nicht das Kapstadt-Virus und nicht das Los Angeles-Virus und nicht das London-Virus. Wir brauchen hier ein ganz großes Technik-Update. Wir können jetzt noch mal dieses Johnson & Johnson und das AstraZeneca-Verfahren einmal durchlaufen lassen. Aber ab Jahreswechsel 2022 brauchen wir hier RNA-Kapazität für die ganze Welt binnen Monatsfristen. Dieser Schritt muss gegangen werden. In Deutschland ist das so schleppend. Wir haben hier die Forschung, aber jetzt brauchen wir auch die Produktion. Dazu gehört auch das Geld und der Staat, der dieses Geld organisiert und der ganze Kram.
Wir brauchen hoffentliche Stimmen, die sich dafür stark machen, um überhaupt zu sagen, das braucht es jetzt, damit es auch einen politischen Willen gibt, der sich dann formt, der sich bildet. Denn das ist ja etwas sehr Bemerkenswertes. Als es irgendwann hieß, Masken schützen, dann gab es eine sehr breite Front von Prominenten, Halbprominenten, von intellektuellen Journalisten, was weiß ich, die alle gesagt haben, jetzt tragt Masken, bastelt Masken, was kann man noch alles tun, damit diese Masken jetzt ganz schnell ankommen und dass sie auch akzeptiert werden. Während das hier bei den Impfstoffen noch immer so aussieht, dass man sich jetzt gerade damit brüstet, ich finde Astra ganz toll und Leute, die Astra skeptisch sind, die fahren auch SUV, leugnen das Klima und haben vielleicht noch was gegen Flüchtlinge. Da haben sie mal versucht, irgendwie so eine ganz merkwürdige, die einen sind die guten Liberalen, das andere sind irgendwie böse Menschen da zu stellen, statt einfach mal zu sagen, ja, in der Notlage frisst der Teufel fliegen, aber die Zukunftstechnologie ist RNA und diese gilt es jetzt nach vorn zu bringen, weil das die einzige Chance ist, dauerhaft aus der Krise zu kommen, wenngleich ich mir bei einigen Leuten schon gar nicht mehr sicher bin, ob sie das überhaupt wollen, sondern eher sagen, na ja, das ist ja irgendwie alles auch ganz interessant, wir fahren das mal noch ein bisschen weiter. Ich finde die ja doch erstaunlich und ich traue es mich kaum zu sagen, aber ich finde es doch erstaunlich, dass die Bildzeitung bei allem Schlimmen, was sie so tut, doch gerade eigentlich die einzige ganz große Zeitung ist, die richtig intensiv Druck macht, die nicht wie Tagesschau und ZDF die ganze Zeit irgendwie versucht, noch diesen Kurs der Bundesregierung zu stützen und der EU den Rücken frei hält. Das Lustigste war ja diese Statistik, du hast sie glaube ich auch gesehen, mit den Ländern, wie weit sie fortgeschritten sind bei den Impfungen. Und dann sah ich plötzlich Deutschland auf Platz drei, da gab es eine Statistik, da dachte ich, ach, habe ich da etwas nicht mitbekommen. Vermisste aber dann beispielsweise Israel, wunderte mich und sah dann unten in der Legende, dass es nur um Länder geht, die mehr als 60 Millionen Einwohner haben. Gut, ich kann sagen, unter den Ländern, durch die der Rhein fließt, ist Deutschland bei den Impfungen auch ganz weit vorne. Also so geht es ja jetzt nur auch nicht, dass wir das Framing verändern. Und insofern bin ich sehr froh, dass die Bildzeitung da ein bisschen Stunk macht, wenngleich ich dann gestern sehr verärgert über die Bildzeitung war, dass man von einem Tabu sprach, Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund sind überdurchschnittlich viel auf Intensivstationen. Und da wurde dann so das Bild von vollen Moschees und von Familienclans, die feiern und was weiß ich, gebildet. Aber was einfach dort nicht stattfand, war, na ja, ganz viele Sektoren, die nach wie vor laufen, wo es kaum Corona-Regeln gibt, die werden, die sind besetzt mit Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund. Zum Beispiel Fleischfabriken und so weiter. Deswegen ist es kein Wunder, dass da die Zahlen hoch sind. Und dass dann auch ein Herr Wieler sich erreistet, denen ein Interview zu geben und auch eigentlich so ein Bild von einer Parallelgesellschaft zeichnet. Das hat mir zum einen zu denken gegeben, zum anderen hat es aber auch noch mal eines deutlich gemacht. Wieler, RKI, das ist nicht einfach so eine freischwebende Intelligenz vollkommen unabhängig, sondern auch die haben politische Stoßrichtungen. Auch die hängen an der Bundesregierung dran. Insofern hat ein Kekole eine viel größere Unabhängigkeit. Und das RKI wollte offenbar, wie Wieler das dann im Interview tat, wieder mal ein Sündenbock und ein Ablenkungsmanöver starten. Nämlich, dann reden wir jetzt mal, können die Muslime keine Masken tragen oder was? Also es wird ja auch immer Migration gleich schon mit Islam verbunden. Können die keine Masken tragen? Und so lange brauchen wir mal nicht über die eigentliche Katastrophe zu reden. Nämlich, dass noch immer das mit dem Schnelltest nicht geklärt ist. Beziehungsweise man jetzt froh sein kann, dass die Discounter offenbar vorsorglich geordert haben, was der Bund verpasst hat.
Ja, das wird ganz, ich hab's heute Morgen schon mal so ein bisschen getwittert, nachdem jetzt wirklich die Meldung kam, dass Aldi ab Montag Schnelltests für 5 Euro das Stück verkauft. Das ist ja auch der Importpreis aus Österreich gerade. An der Stelle noch mal Danke Österreich. Ihr helft uns hier gerade ganz schön aus der Patsche. Wolfgang hat dort bei euch bestellt. Ich hab bei euch bestellt. Wenn Aldi jetzt kommt und sagt, ihr habt Schnelltests für alle, die Volksschnelltests, wo ist eigentlich die Bildschlagzeile, wenn man sie mal braucht, dann könnte man sich ja wirklich überlegen, bis August haben wir uns doch alle dran gewöhnt, wie das mit den Schnelltests funktioniert. In Österreich heißen sie schon Wohnzimmertests, weil du triffst dich ja eh, also kannst du dich auch vorher testen und damit die Gefahr, die individuelle Gefahr senken und gleichzeitig was für die epidemische Gesamtlage tun. Und es könnte durchaus sein, dass Aldi mit dieser eigenen Verfügbarkeitmachung von Schnelltests jetzt uns alle, da wir intrinsisch motiviert genug sind, sie dann auch richtig zu verwenden, in die Lage versetzt zu erkennen, dass es vielleicht richtiger wäre, es wirklich gegen die Politik zu machen. Also nicht nur länger darauf zu warten, dass die Politik irgendeine Strategie macht, sondern sagen, ich brauche keine Teststrategie von Scheuer und Spahn.
Darauf muss ich nicht warten.
Die wurden jetzt eingesetzt in die Taskforce. Und da muss ich sagen, auf die warte ich jetzt nicht, ich mach das jetzt einfach selbst. Also wir bekommen jetzt privaten Besuch am Wochenende und ich habe meine 20 Schnelltests hier. Und die werden natürlich eingesetzt und dann gehen wir alle mal auf Nummer sicher. Und es könnte dann durchaus sein, dass wir im Sommer feststellen, dass wir mit den Schnelltests eigentlich ganz gut klarkommen und unser Umfeld auch, dass sie akzeptiert sind wie Masken. Und dass wir uns dann einfach fragen, warum haben wir das nicht im August 2020 gemacht? Warum haben wir bis August 2021 gewartet? Warum 50.000 Tote? Wenn jetzt immer viele kommen und sagen, wer gegen das Handeln der Regierung ist, der will ja nur Tote in Kauf nehmen. Nee, ich finde, die Regierung ist schuld an den vielen Todesfällen. Denn die Schnelltests waren seit März, April verfügbar. Also wirklich verfügbar. Man hätte sie nur kaufen müssen. Diese Bestellung wurde nie ausgelöst. Keine Ahnung. Ich würde sagen...
Und auch jede Mutlosigkeit bei den Impfungen. Alles, was da versäumt und verpasst wird, was immer noch nicht ausgebaut ist, wo man noch nicht sagt, jetzt aber mal ran, dass man noch versucht hat, auch da wieder einen Sündenbock zu kreieren. Die, die jetzt AstraZeneca kritisieren, Kekole und Co. die seien schuld daran, dass die Leute sich nicht impfen lassen. Vollkommener Unsinn. Ich kenne zig Leute in meinem Umfeld, die würden sofort heute noch die Impfung nehmen. Sie bekommen keine Einladung oder wissen nicht, dass sie sich in gewisser Weise, wenn sie vorerkrankt sind oder so, auch initiativ jetzt noch mal melden könnten und vielleicht Glück haben. Also, dass man so ein narrativer Bild, da muss man auch ganz deutlich sagen, das produziert all dieses Versagen, produziert Tote. Und wir können nicht bei Donald Trump den ganzen, ganz früher Sommer übersagen. Das habt ihr jetzt davon, wenn so ein Trump ist, dann habt ihr hier 100.000 Tote und so weiter. Das kann man jetzt nicht einfach so vergessen und das nicht auch anwenden auf das, was hier gerade passiert. Denn das ist so. Denn es ist die wirklich diese Argumentation, sobald Lockerungen kommen, die Regierung geht, um die Wirtschaft froh zu machen, tausende Tote nimmt sie in Kauf. Aber wir haben jetzt durch Inkompetenz und auch durch einfach eine gewisse Halsstarigkeit dasselbe Phänomen. Wir produzieren extrem viele Tote dadurch, dass so gehandelt wird.
Robin Alexander von der Welt ist so nah dran wie kein anderer Journalist. Auch nicht die vom Spiegel, Feldenkirchen und so. An dem, was da passiert, wenn die zum Beispiel beim Bund und Länder-Treffen zusammensitzen. Er war gestern Abend bei Lanz. Das empfehle ich allen nochmal, sich anzuhören. Und meinte, Merkels Strategie ist doch eigentlich ganz klar. Sie weiß, dass Kontaktreduzierung hilft. Das wissen wir alle. Das Virus wird über Kontakte übertragen. Das kann man dann mathematisch ausrechnen. Umso weniger Kontakte, umso weniger und so weiter. Es gibt aber noch andere Maßnahmen, alternative Maßnahmen. Beispielsweise die Maske, die Schnelltests, die Impfung. Die Impfungen sind knapp. Wir können nicht 80 Millionen, aber zumindest 5 Millionen statt 2 Millionen. Das könnten wir schon mal schaffen gerade. Und dann erklärt Robin Alexander, Merkel hatte Angst, von ihrem Kontaktarmutsgebot abzurücken, weil sie immer die Unterstellung, ihre Verbutung hatte, wenn die Leute Masken aufhaben, halten sie den Abstand nicht mehr ein. Wenn die Leute Schnelltests haben, halten sie den Abstand nicht mehr ein. Also, dass es da ein additives Verfahren gibt, dass wir sagen, wir machen das mit einem Kontaktverbot, aber wir machen auch das mit den Schnelltests und wir machen auch das mit den Masken. Dass es da einen sumarischen Effekt gibt, das hat Merkel dem, würde ich schon sagen, bisschen unterstellten dummen Volk nicht zugestehen wollen. Da hat sie sich zu wenig getraut. Und das rächt sich, glaube ich, weil die Masken und die Antigen-Tests kommen zu spät. Wir wiederholen uns hier, ich wiederhole mich hier. Aber das muss man als Bilanz einfach so ziehen. Und man darf hier durchaus sagen, dass wir alle enttäuscht sind davon, welches Bild Deutschland gerade abgibt, sich selbst gegenüber, aber auch gegenüber der Welt.
History has begun.
History has begun. Also wir gehen jetzt gleich in den Salon und werden da ein Buch lesen. Selten habe ich weniger verstanden, was ein Autor mir sagen will. Selten fand ich die These faszinierender.
Ich finde sie auch sehr faszinierend. Ich habe auch Probleme damit. Manches scheint einem auch sehr quatschig zu sein und dann aber wieder doch nicht. Und vor allem, es ist so eine wunderbare Anleitung, quer zu denken, nicht im Sinne dieser verrückten Querdenker, sondern zu sagen, na, ich sehe das jetzt hier. Das sind all die Fakten. Aber was, wenn es auch ganz anders ist? Also auch gerade zu Themen äußert er sich, warum lieben die Amerikaner Waffen? Und dann sagt er, ja, das sind die liberalen Werte und dass man sich selbst verteidigt. Und eine Skepsis gegenüber dem Staat. Und dann kann man aber auch, wenn man einfach mal mit einer anderen Brille draufblickt, nochmal was ganz anderes, was ganz Neues dazu sagen. Und das ist diese große Stärke dieses Buchs, dass es eine Anleitung ist, die Dinge anders zu betrachten. Und es ist ein Buch, das wir Europäer, glaube ich, sehr gründlich lesen sollten. Es ist von einem europäischen Autor, von einem Portugiesen, was man in meisten Stellen überhaupt nicht merkt, dass hier jemand aus Europa das geschrieben hat. Sondern man denkt eher, das ist jemand, der im amerikanischen Think Tank irgendwo geboren ist. Nein, er kommt eigentlich von außen und zeigt uns hier als Europäer aber auch ganz klar, irgendwo werdet ihr da auch noch eine Rolle spielen, müssen wir mal gucken. Aber das hat jetzt hier nichts mehr mit uns zu tun.
Genau, wir gucken gleich detailliert rein. Ich will es mit einer These und einer Frage an teasern. An der Stelle nur These, im Zweiten Weltkrieg hat Amerika nicht Europa befreit, sondern Amerika hat sich von Europa befreit. Und Frage, ist Donald Trump, kannst du gleich im Salon beantworten, ist Donald Trump der erste wahre amerikanische Präsident? Der nicht einfach nur, ja eigentlich finden wir nur den König blöd, wir gründen mal unseren eigenen, aber wir haben keine Dynastie, also wählen wir uns einen. Ist Donald Trump der erste wahre amerikanische Präsident? Das werden wir gleich mal klären. Ansonsten habe ich noch im Angebot Fabio Di Masis Abschiedsbrief, der ist natürlich wie so ein Vorschlaghammer gegen alle links denkenden Menschen, die zu viel quasseln und zu wenig tun, gedacht. Dann habe ich den Spiegelaufmacher, also vom gedruckten Heft des Spiegel, den Aufmacher gelesen, weil es einfach wirklich eine spektakuläre Corona-Auseinandersetzung ist. Irgendwie ein Dutzend Autoren, mehrere Seiten, wie es halt so ist. Es fällt nicht ein Name eines Politikers. Also ganz große Arbeit vom Spiegel. Allerdings den nur kurz, denn ich wollte auf so ein anderes Gespräch mit Ralf Knispel zurückkommen. Er ist Chef als Oberstaatsanwalt des größten kriminologischen Behördenapparats Deutschlands. Er sagt, hier fällt alles auseinander. Es ist mir peinlich, überhaupt noch vor Gerichte aufzutreten. Dann habe ich Mai Thies Buch gelesen, die kleinste gemeinsame Wirklichkeit. Es ist, wie man sich es vorstellt, wenn ein Verlag sagt, schreib doch mal ein Buch usw. Aber sie hat eine spektakuläre These über Gender Pay Gap drin. Und zwar, weil es da keine Datengrundlage gibt. Und sie sagt es ganz bewusst an, wer die Daten nicht bereitstellt und was man dann trotzdem zum Gender Pay Gap sagen kann und muss. Und da will ich mal weiter noch eine Spekulation anfügen. Außerdem gibt es in Frankreich Kulturkrieg. Die amerikanische Regierung ermittelt jetzt gegen alle Universitäten, weil man den amerikanischen Einfluss dort fürchtet. Vor allem, wenn es in die Islamolefdie Richtung geht. Also, ich war ein bisschen überrascht, ich wusste nichts davon, aber da ist ganz schön was los.
Ja, ich habe viel gelesen, viele Bücher gelesen. Und das eine habe ich schon angekündigt, Karl und ich. Battista Giabicconi erzählt die Geschichte, wie es im Untertitel heißt, einer besonderen Freundschaft. Aber ich würde präziser sein und sagen, es ist die Geschichte einer Liebe. Aber eine ganz andere Liebe als das, was die meisten von uns unter Liebe wohl verstehen. Und es ist ein Buch, das so aus allem rausfällt, was dort geschildert wird, was man sonst unter Freundschaft, Liebe verstehen kann. Auch wie geht man eigentlich mit so einer Hierarchie um? Ein 18-jähriges Model lernt diese Berühmtheit kennen und hat eine große Lust daran, muse zu sein. Ein hochinteressantes Buch. Dann auch das schon angekündigt von mir, warum man nicht mehr ich liebe dich sagen sollte. Das klären wir heute mit dem Philosophen Francois Julien. Und dann habe ich ein unglaublich gutes Buch gelesen. Noch im Reclang Verlag erschienen jetzt die Epistämisierung des politischen, wie die Macht des Wissens, die Demokratie gefährdet. Wir sagen doch alle, jetzt hören wir doch mal auf die Wissenschaft. Und da sagt Alexander Burkner, nee, so einfach ist das nicht. Und ich finde, er hat Recht. Und dann schauen wir uns noch zwei kleine Phänomene an.
Sehr gut, der technische Hinweis, die Frage kommt nämlich am häufigsten. Ihr müsst den Salon, wenn ihr den Salon gebucht habt, nicht auf der Webseite im Webplayer hören, sondern ihr kriegt einen eigenen RSS-Feed. Den könnt ihr in eurem Podcatcher, in Podcatcher eurer Wahl, also bei Apple Podcasts oder wo auch immer, Overcast, Pocketcast abonnieren. Das ist dann euer ganz eigener, der ist genauso lange gültig, wie Zahlung eingeht. Nur bei Spotify kann man nicht importieren, denn bei Spotify muss man in einem Katalog gelistet sein. Aber ansonsten kann man überall, wie man es kennt, den Salon konsumieren. Und für die Frage, wo ist mein SS-Feed? Ja, Steady hat ihn ein bisschen versteckt, aber er ist in der Bestätigungs-Mail. Ich habe es auch auf die Seite noch mal geschrieben. Man bekommt seine Bestätigungs-Mail und da ist er drin verlinkt. Man muss sich nicht auf der Seite Tod suchen, da ist er zwar auch irgendwo, ich weiß echt nicht wo, aber in der Bestätigungs-Mail ist er drin. Da kann man dann einfach rüber kopieren und dann kann man dem Salon folgen. Und natürlich, man bekommt alle alten Salon-Folgen, wenn man bucht. Man ist dann nicht erst ab jetzt freigeschaltet oder so, sondern man kriegt dann inzwischen mehr als ein Jahr Salon geliefert. Sehr gut, na dann gehen wir mal rein.
Vielen Dank!